oktar mokhtar ça va ça va ya les enfants
bocar ce soir une personne très spéciale
est venu sur ce plateau pour vous
annoncer quelque chose d'important
cette personne n'est jamais encore venu
dans notre émission ça pulse est
conscient que la vérité qui compte vous
rappeler de cette émission de tf1
présenté par pascal bataille et laurent
fontaine et bien je vous le dis il ya
des torrents d'émotion qui ont été
déversées dans cette émission sur tf1
et bien je peux vous dire que ce soir on
va tous être trempé comme isabelle vous
parlez de du happening et bien sûr parce
que la personne qui est derrière le
rideau est ici pour parler à mokhtar
mokhtar qui est là qui est installé vos
tâches que vous avez une idée de qui se
cache derrière le rideau
non vraiment pas ce qu'on pouvait parler
plus fort parce que je ne vous entends
pas non vraiment pas pas ceux qui t'ont
la motta pensées vont à une personne que
vous avez totalement perdus de vue
perdus de vue oui c'est à dire pas vu
depuis longtemps
je peux vous poser une question
maintenant quel réseau pourquoi y'a
toujours un casque enfin cacher devant
les yeux c'est toujours mieux balkans au
cas où il prend l'avion dash est ce que
il ya quelqu'un qui a quelque chose à
vous reprocher mokhtar non bon quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors aux motards il ya un premier
indice écoutez et regardez chez vous qui
va peut-être vous mettre sur la voie de
qui est cette personne regarde mokhtar
que penses tu du dicton tunisien une
seule babouche vous manque et tout est
dépeuplé commence à avoir une idée
mokhtar ou pas non aux pasdaran ont fait
ça n'ont pas pour l'instant
non aucune dana white qui je veux parler
ou pas du tout n'entend pas un autre
indice il ya un deuxième indice écouter
bonjour me tard tu as dit que le rugby
était la deuxième famille mais pour être
tout plaquer pour la première fois ont
presque commencé à y voir plus clair
on a un petit peu heureux
pensez à qui ma mère au cas où vous les
enlevez le le cash avions
vos casques vous voulez voir qui se
cache derrière le rythme moi oui
là je peux vous dire
je met à côté de mon mokhtar mokhtar on
va vous montrer tout de suite qui est
derrière le rideau
regardez qui veut vous parler ce soir
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
merci d'être là même si elle est la pop
star monde au qatar en autarcie athénée
merci d'être là on affirme la maman de
deux motards de tunisie et elle a
quelque chose à dire à mokhtar oui
mokhtar je veux ni aujourd'hui esprit
pauvres parce que je t'aime boucraut et
je vais avoir mon petit fils aussi et je
voyais à elle n'est pas venue seule ce
soir à bogota
oui elle a une surprise pour pour
mokhtar ce soir et je pense que ça va
lui faire très très plaisir on voulait
lui faire une surprise déjà qui va
partir à las vegas déjà il va être comme
un fou je vous dis vous pouvez bien avec
n'ouvre la porte à madame hortense qu il
n y avait qu à las vegas l'apathie
moka manta est une surprise que tu as
fait ça ta maman ce soir est-ce que tu
étais content d'abord parce que tunisie
et quand il est comment vous pas vu pour
y dormir à la maison soit mokhtar vous
êtes venu avec qui je venais avec 921
donc fatiha elle est venue avec mes
soeurs jumelles mais des gros soeur
jumelle j'ai pas vu depuis deux trois
ans avec les soeurs jumelles de votre
part qui l'a pas vu depuis trois ans
[Applaudissements]
s'il atteint attendant votez pour vos
séries au choix ouais ouais ça fait
trois ans que tu les as pas vu tes
soeurs et quoi et tu y vas tu as des
soeurs jumelles comme ça ça fait comment
tomber et a vu trois ans pour vous le
regardez pas la télé ou pas bien les
jours et tous les jours il est
formidable oui est ce que cette formule
c'est un cadeau que je voulais de faire
ce soir
elles sont venues voilà devoir de
tunisie elles vont rester avec toi elles
vont te bichonner maman va rester la
rasd ma mort annonçant occupera alors
ben moctar du très heureux pour toi
exploite sa maman merci de la matière
fatiha et mocquard est vraiment je suis
très heureux que ce sont les vieux merci
et je crois que c'est une magnifique
surprise programme d'art voilà mon chéri
et ben on voulait de faire la surprise
cet art en tunisie c'est elle qui reste
mais si tu veux vous allez tous c'est
pour moi c'est cadeau je vous ai réservé
l'hippopotamus juste passer un bon
moment auquel fort merci
merci d'abonnés haut débit si on avait
tous les cieux mercier est les deux
soeurs de mokhtar magnifiques arbres et
merci beaucoup carte
merci papa merci mais cheikh ibra bourré
il a failli me faire chialer ce qu'on
l'a non mais c'est pas franchement mes
mouvements jean-luc s'était pas fou sans
déconner aussi j'aime pas plus real
antennes je suis sensible jaunards mais
mais mais mais mais mokhtar là je peux
vous dire la salle ça lui a fait quelque
chose on a des nouvelles de nora et
nohra